[Musique]
la première idée 18h14
bonsoir musique et littérature au
programme cette semaine quatre invités
et voici d'abord urbain philéas et
daniel maillot pour la comédie musicale
voix de brousse où l'univers enchanté de
trois grilles aux malgaches réunionnais
et africains tabarly en 2018 troisième
édition au port y met le libraire
lanlaire avec plein d'invités de la zone
est d'ailleurs expédié en europe nous en
dit plus dans culture premières enfin
poésie réunionnaise avec le livre de
khadra ma famille nous traînions un
stand fanal et en sous titre que
l'histoire points funcom la réunion
enfin galma touahri qui nous emmènera à
salazie je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
nous suivre en direct sur réunion la
première culture première jean-paul
milad bon sang quelle comme chaque jeudi
je vous laisse la parole et vous nous
donner des idées de sorties pour cette
fin de semaine exactement après le
travail et peut-être les petites
contrariétés de la semaine je vous
propose d'aller vous requinquer à hell
bourg dans la fraîcheur du cirque de
salazie
figurez vous que j'y ai trouvé un musée
mais pas n'importe lequel
c'est l'un des plus beaux musées de la
réunion c'est le musée des musiques et
instruments de l'océan indien
suivez le guide c'est parti imaginez
chers auditeurs vous êtes en plein
centre de hell bourg et là vous tombez
sur la maison morange qui hébergement
fameux musée vous passer le seuil et
vous découvrez une magnifique collection
d'instruments instruments que l'on
retrouve dans le maloya mais aussi dans
les musiques asiatique malgache et
africaine
bref vous l'aurez compris je vous emmène
voir un musée qui présente les musiques
des diverses communautés installées à la
réunion on commence la visite déjà dans
le hall vous apercevez des instruments
comme le kayamb le roulèr le bob et j'en
passe sur votre droit et sur votre
gauche plus grande salle d'exposition
une salle consacrée à la musique
chinoise et à ses instruments
une autre qui présente la musique de
l'inde dans une autre encore vous sont
embarqués pour le moyen-orient à la
découverte de la musique arabe et de
l'un de ces instruments fétiches le luth
pour vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
les instruments gueule bien sûr jean
paul en fait on va près de 400
instruments
autant le dire c'est beaucoup il ya des
instruments à cordes délire des arts des
cithares des violons il ya des
instruments à vent aussi des cordes et
trompe un des hauts bois
on a même des cloches des
tambours des gongs en tout cas l'un de
ces instruments
et bien pour ce qui concerne ces
instruments ils viennent d'un peu
partout de l'afrique à l'asie du sud on
va dire en passant par le proche orient
vous avez des arbres de birmanie et du
congo vous avez des vielles de mongolie
d'élus d'afghanistan et du maroc des
chéneaux phone du sénégal et même des
instruments d'indonésie la seule chose
que l'on peut déplorer c'est que la date
de fabrication des instruments ne soit
pas indiqué alors j'ai pris mon papi
girls sur très embêté c'est pas très
grave
alors en tant que guide je poursuis la
visite avec mes auditeurs imaginez vous
vous êtes donc dans ce musée
vous avez votre audio guide en main et
vous parcourez à votre rythme chacune
des salles du musée où vous pouvez faire
trois choses vous regardez des vidéos de
danse et de chants traditionnels
vous pouvez écouter des enregistrements
sonores et évidemment vous pouvez
également lire tous les textes
explicatifs et les vous dire jean paul
ce qui fait la saveur un peu spéciale de
ce musée à mon avis c'est qu'ils
exposent aussi de très belles statues
des masques des tableaux et même des
photos et j'ai oublié
on a aussi des reconstitutions
reconstitution d'un salon de musique d'
un maharaja reconstitution d'un
intérieur chinois ou encore
reconstitution de l'atelier d'un
fabricant de lutte
voilà c'est ce dépaysement musical et
architectural qui fait le sel de ce
musée alors donc c'est à hell bourg du
mardi au dimanche de 10h à 18h merci
galles merci m
culture première deux invités pour
commencer ce magazine que non que l'on
présente plus urbain filasses et de
refrains connus pour moi en tous les cas
du grand mont a déjà là je dire alain
mailhot et pourtant c'est lui qui a
écrit le scénario voix de bruce une
comédie musicale réunionnaise mais
parker alors je vous résume le synopsis
depuis des millénaires il existe un
ordre établi par le créateur seuls les
hommes ont le droit de faire chanter les
coeur de la forêt les femmes ont
l'interdiction formelle de le faire un
jour une voix enchanteresse c'est une
femme bien sûr domine celle des autres
les voies de la brousse décide donc de
rétablir l'ordre primitif
un parcours qui va durer sept jours en
se ruant limbourg sera l'un des trois
est un peu discriminant droit ou dans
les soirs oui mais après l'audience il
viendra que les bons alors que daniel
donc c'est ou que d'accepter de la
houlette du rhum cubain ne vois-tu des
gens que meilleur comment sauver
l idée générale de l'histoire et en
moins mme harvey pas de yemma complète
un peu son histoire m'a développe ce
moment d'y remédier au plus tôt
développe son histoire on histoire à
finhan elle peut plus plus plus élaboré
une voie dit à la base j'avais trois
alignements arrivée m 20 ans était
contrôlé mais à moi c'est le après ma
vie mon vision moins et malgré un ip en
gros on ne vient ni d'une voix et après
mahdi ben messaoud écrit il a écrit en
fait on considère de montéty content et
bien il a décrit sa clémence et motivés
et appliqués que ça vous l'avez très
exactement au départ et jusqu'à le banc
dès le début comme un tollé en fait mon
cinquième album et mathis dire quelqu'un
fait un clip est là quelqu'un présente
en moins et daniel et après
là où s'est posée la mythique où
quelqu'un qui écrit les capable de faire
comme si c'était sur commande ou trois
mois mais je n'ai pas fait ce boulot
daniel daniel et banana dernier et bana
il travaille t il réaliser un clip pour
les plus grands la réunion la digos et
tout de suite
et comme moi beaucoup le moment le match
c'est plus beau le court métrage musical
à travers d'un clip mais il n'est pas
encore est un court métrage est vrai qu
métrage ça va venir
on ne bâtit pas d'accord donc à peu près
donc la connaît depuis trois ans mais
l'idée même qu'on la violence que ça
c'est que l'année dernière à 2 ans et de
sa belle et ouais le pacifique ce qu'ils
sont tous intéressés travail - d'ici un
projet et puis dans un temps donné qu'en
tant que fan a causé ou là où il a fait
vingt lignes il a fait 3e donc 17 pouces
3 nous l'avons un peu le temps cette
dignité grèce ouais il va dire cette
ligne car les crimes et ben ouais quand
même parce que c'est un projet qui doit
démarrer vite un laps de temps très
court
donc du coup m'a appelé un quinzaine
vingtaine de joueurs poetry sage
non mais à la base ou les quoi
exactement où la masse
en vérité pour la phase finale
réalisateur mon collègue stéphane une
autre acception picturale ou plus où se
nouent la norme à séoul au et stéphane
carrade donc voilà en effet fait à peu
près 15 les mélanges la route dont avec
l'épée continent comme dj avec l'indigo
comme ça d'accord ok donc je connais pas
mal de monde
elle en a quatre personnages principaux
maladie trois tailles à l'âme et
volontairement mennella 4 en fait l'ena
ce domaine
le narrateur au coriace mais pour nous
le plus vieux au fond d'un pot au feu ou
la calomnie at home by that can be that
obrad donc et puis donc une manne
malgache olena marwan zein
mais ce n est pas de 10 à monaco et puis
mike mason chef des choeurs de la forêt
du monde entier la commune personnes sur
scène un autre explique un petit peu
quand cela parce que le personnage
arrive sur scène et n'a tout un
puisqu'il y arrive dans la métropole
avec un hoverboard faut pas qu'ils
veulent
en gros le spectacle sur les manigances
ses nombreuses mais en fait on a trois
sages mais le premier point des siens
avant que banal a été saisie ces trois
là c'est sur le même le premier depuis
haut débit c'est le boss voilà essayé en
fait compte mais lille a10 avec icsi
soit là et c'est pour ça qu'on m'a aidé
à aller soit salvail
il trompe à noter un peu de direction
c'est ça ma fait quoi dans l'histoire le
musée ça va pendant sept jours
alors est ce que l'histoire se passe
uniquement dans un seul lieu où alors il
bouge ça va en afrique et à madagascar
ça valait la nôtre et bougies voyage
madagascar l'afrique est à l'union et
par tout un pays daniel d'accord comme
par hasard est de 7 jours 7 nuits oui
mais cette journée but fait bizarre non
une explication pas su arrive en cours
du spectacle vous comprendra pas oui et
là dedans on a un petit bout de deux
mois à la hausse et qu'il est donc là
par exemple est maçon d'accord je reçois
de plus facile trouva au madagascar
conte africain après après les autres au
fossé l'africain est un parti de folie
laissez pas aller d un peu comme ça et
le salon des seigneuries jeune entité
dur c'est à dire mais de tergnier c'est
un peu des deux mon enfance c'est pas
comme si nous sommes mis d'accord c'est
le jeune et surprise peut-être courtois
le contenu les surplus la famille fils
acétate dans mon beignets ses épines a
beaucoup d'étrangers qui m'habite
résistance aussi banal travail comme ça
des amis sinon on a beaucoup de monde vu
bannière sait apprécier tout baigne
nouveau parce qu'en faisant de lui le
principe cci de lens aussi c'est une
belle ne les nouveaux que les
les paniques assène alors hop a de
nouveau comme nadine nouveau d'en
montrer compris nouveau new moon
étrangers mais en fin de compte ces
nouveaux de la famille donc grèce même
enfin mieux le client non conformes 50
ans le plus jeune 18 ans 15 ans au mieux
ça c'est bien de nouveau et après midi
comme ça et si vieux que ça que le
commandement de dons à le canal est à 10
10 la famille aussi mais la plaie passer
des nièces la plupart ces derniers qui
forme de droits d'accès pour être bel
équilibre est il de l'histoire de
l'homme alors oui justement alors
l'homme était un orgueilleux mais a
toujours été régulier même de la
jeunesse at il des coups ils voient bien
madame michu et ben non pas parce que ça
passe avant de présenter son attente et
son design se promettent ils sont déjà
là les bleus font comme madame dit
madame tussauds longtemps avant pas bien
oui et après midi les moments où ça
commence passer tout d'un coup ma vie
qui des messieurs et puis il ya des
trois années les dames bien non c'est
que n'oublie ce qui est à nous et on ne
connaît pas ce qu'ils avaient belle
histoire est pareil quand tu dis là en
fait que l'histoire quand même c'est
qu'il ne parle d'histoire nous pas
relaté m
la capelle acapella le début du tout ils
commencent pas à m'expliquer nos il ya
deux corées courant copine moi sa façon
en d'accord répétitions ont commencé
daniel mailhot pardon à la mairie les
faits et répulsion a commencé dans
longtemps ok tous les joueurs là même le
ballon répulsion actuellement écoute as
a way
me prendre quand même pas sûr qu'en
écoutant nous la font comme s'il me
reste donc nous nous mettons retard mais
une vidéo il faut mettre droit à l'eau
me padva où la question parce que je me
connais pas sur l'inconnu ground son
papa mais est ce que la belle est aussi
rigoureux que ce papa c'est ça qui
arrive en retard tout sa cliente il est
tjrs à 500 euros dessus faisant des
fautes et 700 francs après le samedi ça
balayait et d'un grand service à tout le
monde il a et b cet outil là se passe un
truc est pas trop bien au niveau
opposition dans semaine mais samedi me
mettre toute droite
d'accord elle m l'appoint des lapins
deviennent famille famille quand il
répète un coin d'accord ok bon première
représentation ou sa cité des arts
samedi
la semaine prochaine ce qui leur
apparaît bonnet parce qu'il est pas
servi qui sait tout et si gérard est un
peu en retard par pour le spectacle aux
ped v2 deuxième succès 19 mai salle g
libreoffice scission d'accor a repris
ses polos caf en septembre saison le 13
et j bon d'accord moi je me serais
obligé de réviser mon accent est
vraiment très molle merci en tous les
cas d'année le maillot merci
[Musique]
urbain urbain peut-être que mon
spectacle
si manning pas le temps d'annoncer la
pensée d'accord ok merci et écoute sans
[Musique]
nadia la nati là
piquez la mi-séance à gaza
un autre média dino hoya
vim
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas le sens d'un déni tan tan
anonymat des critiques d'états d'âme à
ce niveau
[Musique]
voilà merci fitiavana nominés
[Applaudissements]
louvel
[Musique]
obama nominale ou bello
il fallait qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de ça
c'est baba d'accord et ce morceau là il
va entendre se reprend spectacle si la
bande originale de la comédie musicale
d'accord et ses morceaux
oui alors ce moment cela est
nous la région devenir à sens parce que
c'est mon solal est là pourquoi sociaux
et comptes d'accor et quand il est venu
à la réunion pour le festival encore
willy h entre cela et puis match qu'il a
pris et m'a dit vous messieurs st tite
dépit de ce titre là alors ils sont
vraiment ces gens là casa pizza bamanan
soit le plus grand ok ben voilà donc
baba c'est son nom d'artiste dans la ba
ba ba 90 hisse donc le la semaine
prochaine samedi 21 avril cité des
artisans à partir de 20h20 merci de nous
coûter jusqu'à 40 secondes qui fini
[Musique]
tous
mais sache voilà notre dernière demi
heure est consacrée à la littérature
réunionnaise est d'abord avec vous
expedite sur nos impôts on verra comment
s'habiller bonsoir salon du livre des
mondes créoles aux personne n'est payé
une prouesse non ben écoute ne l'est un
peu obligé parce que lofis la lang n'est
pas très riche mais au final on est
aussi capable de mobiliser beaucoup de
bénévoles est en tout cas l'équipe qui
travaille dessus aucun de nous les payer
alors ma demande est juste tout du petit
coup de micro parce que toi pourquoi une
micro n'est comme sa voix voilà merci
beaucoup
alors certes troisième édition troisième
édition mais un vote n'est pas comme en
non alors avant de nous taper sa cabale
yves mai 2010 comprend pas trop des dix
kabar live a été confondu avec le
cabaret situé rue de nice à saint denis
donc nous la réfléchi ensemble ne l'a
décidé de transformer un peu le nom mais
tout en gardant l'idée du kabar c'est à
dire en fait jubilatoire et autour du
livre dont on l'a changé légèrement
ludique à bali lire comme ça j'ai un nom
qui fait fait pas il prête pas à
confusion
alors le cabaret à madagascar c'est
quelque chose de particulier revenons à
proposer un dispositif un concept espace
de réunion à l'ars
ok alors cette troisième édition comme
d'habitude fait venir de monde ici dans
deux ans de moins de monde
2 qui appartient au mot créole des
différentes parties du monde dans la
mesure où les gens acceptent de venir
évidemment donc nous on aura des invités
qui vient des antilles de la zone
caraïbe
beaucoup d'invités de la zone océan
indien évidemment puisque ses deux plus
proches voisins maurice rodrigues
seychelles on aura aussi des invités des
comores donc tout ce monde-là qui
participent à la créolité pour mettre en
l'air le livre la littérature pas
seulement écrite d'ailleurs puisque
donnant quand même certain que les
exclusivement de la littérature orale
pour autour de l'expression de la
créolité qu'elle s'exprime en français
ou en créole qui est par exemple alors
par exemple sur seychelles nana andrex
rosalie que les gens ne font que de là
bas mais que pas comment ce tir passa
aux seychelles mais livadia nous tous
pour les antilles noah fabienne kanor
est une écrivaine assez connu encore
jeunes de céline antillaise qui vient en
faudra une anti halal est d'origine
antillaise c'est une fille de
l'immigration elle y vit en france
mais bon elle écrit aussi sur les
antilles et aussi sur l'universalité
incessants bonne livre n'est pas
exclusivement sur montreux cantonné sur
le lille niveau gerrard est bon c'est
quelqu'un de talent elle me l'a
découvert à cette occasion là mais mal
et déjà enchanté par son écriture
après non à quelqu'un qui sait vraiment
qui mérite d'être signalé tout le monde
est bien mais pour me signaler c'est
mickaël ferrié nicolas ferrier c'est
celui que ça soit heureuse on peut pas
dire ça aux comores et joe veut
justement l'a bien vite les gens
vraiment à venir voir écouter michaël
ferrier à au salon au cabba relire du
porc parce que michaël ferrier c'est un
gars que les particules et mamie
considère l'idée un créole du monde
parce que line a des origines multiples
française évidemment avec un nom comme
ça mais aussi malgache mauricienne
réunionnaise les vivent au japon où il
est enseignant à l'université de tokyo
et c'est quelqu'un qui considère que le
japon est le degré zéro de la créolité
ah bon alors mais justement il faut
venir entendre sa conférence et le
revoir dans une conférence à une
conférence
jeudi soir à la mairie de saint denis
puisque la mairie thani est partenaire
de l'office pour la première fois cette
année donnera une conférence sur le
japon est-il degré zéro de la créolité
est vif
il faut avouer que avant ça nous avait
jamais pensé trouver une once de
créolité et au japon dont michaël
ferrier c'est quelqu'un a une approche
complètement original et diva explique à
nous tout ça est donc comme il vient de
dire il a bien le prix athéna de l'année
dernière soit est ce que lui il est de
finir qui délivre aussi oui c'est un
écrivain que la fim écrire au moins cinq
ou six livres notamment des essais aussi
sur la catastrophe de fukushima qui la
vivent en direct et là son dernier livre
pour lequel il a gagné le prix athéna
ses mémoires d'outré mer et donc il
revient sur les traces de son grand père
à madagascar
donc les vraiment intéressant en a
maintenant hâte de rencontrer cet écrit
à l'adresse ip phones iphone urbain il
faut il faut il faut il faut découvrir
cet homme là bon ok on connaît ou deux
mais khalifa du code ramassamy été en
contact avec axel gauvin la demande de
rapprochement de la réunion des livres
pour faire partie de tabarly d'accord ok
avec toi c'est que tu proposes explique
on a un peu la réponse servie c'est
comprendre par rapport à aux gens qu
écrit en français comme michaël faye et
maryvonne barioz comment tu peux être
inclus dans affaire comme ça ils
concernent le monde créole alors
maryvonne barrios est un peu particulier
c'est parce que le thème de ce gabarit
et cette année c'est les devinettes
notre conseil choisi la réunion qui
appelle ciron d'un amour estime tim aux
antilles donc marie maryvonne vario que
me connaît pas encore elle vient des
charentes et c'est aussi pour montrer
pour faire le lien entre les racines
africaines incontestable des devinettes
que les dans les mondes créoles mais que
finalement il existe aussi en france le
quai sous le nom de binhai façon et
c'est ça d'avoir avait vu ciudad de
villages ont mis pour traiter mon dieu
alone on devine assez réunionnais de moi
que je suis trop ça qu'on veut toujours
que ça change maintenant on a tendance à
dire aussi sirandane alors que cyrano
départ t'es pas un mot de la réunion
c'est un mode et maurice a d'ailleurs
mbuka celui ci rend compte que le
soutient maurice denis
dernièrement oui celui dans nos corps
pourront peut-être non me croque sable
blanc le sait pas l'occasion
moi c'est de retrouver sur le net mais
enfin à l'express de maurice événements
des possibles l'année senti pour les 50
ans d'indépendance dans le gabarit alors
non encore pour rendre ce qui nous
manque en france est un
université à mauriciens que celui que la
piloter le critt yoff comme en prenant
la personne grafi larmoni donc les
linguistes les travaille à l'université
maurice mais ces quelques allées tout le
temps la réunion nous connaît allait
bien à lire et à tous que l'officier et
pourquoi pas vu tabous comme avant lui
son nom comme brad gilbert pounia
d'akira chômé dablé là tous les ans les
vrais oui c'est un grand copain un homme
pour qui mena une admiration infinie
non mesdames cette année peut-être n'est
pas disponible mais ne l'ayez pas du
tout exclu vite hélas les deux
précédents cas ben ali a aidé il est là
aussi dans tous les colloques que
l'office il fédère une bouteille pour
que le créole utilisait à la note encore
lily estime que l'anglais est un créole
les verts eux oui bon et si un jaune à
l'occasion il a expliqué sa position
alors ben mahmoud saïd yeux je
commandais comment rien oui bah
justement elle va découvrir parce que
peut-être du fait que nous nous parle de
créolité peut-être nous croient que na
poin le lien avec les comores avec
mayotte et c'est messi parce que nous
les nous les imbriqués les uns dans les
autres et c'est ça que lecavalier 8 met
en avant les sera très intéressant
découvrir et découvrir les devinettes
des comores ou parce que comment la liga
samedi pont comme on vient pour un
guadeloupéen mais peut encore comprendre
que vianney seychelloise et rats comment
y avait des comoriens au début du
peuplement absolument nous les lier même
ne l'est nous les vraiment en étroit on
est trois liens les uns avec les autres
c'est des choses à développer d'accord
donc voilà donc c'est ce que je dois
faire
voilà donner un petit peu le programme
puisque les nao
oui et comment ce n'est nulle part
mercredi soir voilà le 18 c'est la
soirée inaugurale à la médiathèque
mais la veille c'est mercredi d'accord
mercredi c'est la soirée inaugurale avec
déjà une conférence un sur justement les
devinettes avec un hommage au roi caf en
musique
et après tout les joues à ton mena les
stones des libraires et des éditeurs sur
le salon et toute la journée le matin et
l'après midi nous ne nions une séance
d'une heure et quart de rencontre entre
un auteur et le public
le matin les menées par notre camarade a
référé à l'après midi par moi même donc
là des écrivains d'ici et d'ailleurs
il discute avec le public josette livre
nous présente le livre discute en
fonction créole là où l'autre encore par
exemple isabelle warhol a écrit un livre
et loi gilles non le préfet noir dans le
livre est à moitié créole puisque c'est
un livre bilingue mais évident que la ne
sans parler de la partie créole après
bat michaël ferrier fabien canonnier
crypte en créole réunionnais mais le cas
ben ali de la créolité les pas refermées
sur la langue créole c'est la façon dont
la créolité s'exprime au contraire très
intéressante pour les gens de découvrir
que catherine a beau écrire en français
pour axel gauvin axel gauvin et rit
beaucoup de livres en français mais
c'est un français qui il est vraiment
mâtiné de créole on ne peut pas dire que
c'est pas de la créolité qui s'exprime
au travers ses ouvrages
oui souvent les auteurs des désirs
utilisent le français parfois nous
offrons sénat quand même pouvoir dire
est une pièce de régionalisme à
l'intérieur oui et en fait tu veux moi
me considère que c'est une grande
réussite de nos mondes créoles d'avoir
réussi à transcender cette langue
française comme nous a imposée au début
mais d'avoir dépassé cet aspect là et
d'en faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire puisque actuellement
les plus grands noms de la littérature
francophone il vient des mondes créoles
onana lyonel trouillot par exemple
multiples et un grand nom de la
francophonie la littérature francophone
weiss en haïti avant salariés mais c'est
zé alive edouard glissant et patrick
chamoiseau et à la réunion axel gauvin
jean-françois samlong tous ces gens là
zot y écrit en français
l'essai foncez que nous la réapproprient
à nous quel est le nôtre et qui ne
devait pas le même français que marc
levy ou d'enfants tous et tout certains
écrits des best-sellers ses compensées
au bon d'accord ok donc idiot d'autres
quel bateau pilote alors du 18 au 21 18
21 les lieux parce que le port n'a pas
que le port si le port et saint denis la
mairie de l'année c'est que la
conférence du jeudi soir tout le reste
du temps c'est au port dans le hot au
toit de l'office de la langue la rue
léon de lepervanche en face de l'église
jeanne d'arc avec des rencontres aussi à
la médiathèque du porc au théâtre sous
les arbres notamment pour la dernière
soirée là une grande soirée
devine aille au toit des six rondes
année des concerts chose au théâtre sous
les arbres
et puis non un programme scolaire pour
les enfants de l'élémentaire et de
collèges toute la journée notamment
vendredi matin toute une matinée sera
consacrée aux enfants avec danyel waro
autour de son livre
warden qui émaillent une année notre
chanteur aussi vu son nom et sera là
lundi noir ou dépassé pas aux visiteurs
non non c'est pas c'est pas un salon
autour de la musique
mais nous ne nous excluent pas la
musique comme daniel waro nana un livre
qu'il a fait avec les enfants donc là
c'est l'occasion de voir que enfin que
du maloya et que les très ouvert sur le
maloya donc la matinée du vendredi sera
entièrement consacré à sa et commence à
mixer le fait d'attendre ramassamy sera
là pour son bouquet d'accord ok bon
merci en tous les cas expéditionnaire la
up
c'est les deux ce paquet pas que c'est
nous et puis ben rappelons le début 18
avril jusqu'au 21 merci à tous bien
l'après midi le ahly même le ter que mes
animaux au quai 18h45 de culture
première musique
[Musique]
pour
- même quasi me connais pas lire ne
connais pas lire ne connais pas écrire
colis à mon journal comme il faut
hier tu connais pas les intentions dans
longtemps ça n'était pas drôle
la patrouille se mêler paul méric
ingrate est planté voilà des mêmes il
fait n'importe quoi comme la tour mon
frère
ma crainte qu'ils soient rares et perd
même moment l'amour
make me dit ali
moi-même qassimi amicaux n'est pas lié à
mi koné pa liens amicaux n'est pas
écrire colis à montchanin casimir
connais pas les autres
koné palliatifs je n'ai pas écrit
[Musique]
m
moi-même kazimiyah mi koné pa li yan
nepali amicaux n'est pas écrire ou lire
mon journal comme il faut les remplacer
mais pas lyon connaît pas
mon beau père la di monda
[Musique]
mayer
moquée wade a moins
c'est petit même qassimi connais pas il
me connaît pas lien ne connaît pas
écrire ou lire mon journal
peut-être
mais ne connais pas les amicaux ne pâlit
amicaux n'est pas écrit
lire mon journal comme il faut
remplie poutine
cadets
[Musique]
ouais
oizo enfants exo été ça un jeu et
oiseaux - n'a jamais vu une affaire
comme ça t noté 10 passes ou chaos ou
comprend m'ont causé iv est tout ballon
tu es managament radio nous ça bat karé
ensemble le sien y arrive taiso raout
est la même la mise à bèze
berradi un roce tout de suite là aïe aïe
aïe le ciel cours en criant ceux qui
cotisent promenade
le ca thierry son tour o'connell sagong
oui la suivent à moins prend 7 buts du
bois là pour poids qu'a dit aïe aïe aïe
le ca tikrit en cours ont ainsi continué
tous deux promenades en même temps le
loup y arrive
tda loncin et d'où ça vient au thé me la
donnes à au poil et c'est là qu'est le
z'oiseaux is over ip de son sommet il
tombe des trous t ous avez mon oiseau al
ahly la tombe d'un trou aux enfants
itier sur le pack l'oiseau en même temps
un tank pital hi hi hi hi ben on doit
pousser fait mal aïe aïe aïe moment mon
dieu seigneur mise à mort oumou oiseaux
ibouth phi une île à la tremblade des 6
ou a causé tant de la picao assise à
même blouse par aspersion maladie
personnes étiez douleur attendent bouge
pas mais ça trappe le fleuve jaune avec
un pédalo ou routis beck ou médias ou en
val de lots attendent la freddy un pays
où libre - s'immiscera la monf idir
monts valin typé de l'america ramassamy
alors ça c'est un ça s'appelle enfants
exo l'estrie appel nous traînons east et
nout finale de soul a manqué contre
histoire profonde coeur de la réunion
d'accord alors puisque une à deux mondes
spécialistes l'a expédié coup mamie veut
connaître la différence que nenê en
train un conte l histoire profondeur à
ce que nenê pour moi la différence mais
trop me trompe pas
alors la différence chacun quand il
écrit ni version vision des choses et
moi c'est comme un petit peu les goûts
les couleurs et ils discutent pas
sereinement son manière de voir alors le
conte le compte les plus imaginer et les
histoires si on a fait l'espace est
libre et c'est une réalité ces
histoires-là se passer longtemps
longtemps les plus long qu'un compte 1
contre les plus adaptées les enfants
d'exposition les d'accord avec 100 de
finisseur et que le fun qu'il recouvre
tout puisque le fun classe et ceux qui
sortent de nous et c'est ce que nous
exprime dedans il peut avoir et les
histoires il peut avoir des comptes tu
peux avoir les poèmes
on a des gens qui utilisent un mot
fonnkèr exclusivement pour la poésie
mais moi aussi même à métro que le
flanker s'élançant parce que l'un à des
textes en prose que les défendent caire
d'accord ok donc faudra un jeune homme
automne comme d'aqaba oui mais de toute
façon tout ça est construit au fur et à
mesure ouais tipa tipa mais stabilisé
pour moi fonker c'est un poème c'est
même affaire pour moi et pas pour tous
les cas alors le fond c'est un cri vient
étayer c'est un petit peu mon vécu
ou sinon un message qu'on veut faire
passer parce que tout ce qu'elle a été
fait là dedans ne va pas ou de livre
justement l'ena dont faisait partie
d'aucune retournera quatre parties
d'arena contes histoires créole points
ce week-end à six contre trois histoires
huit poèmes obtenez un peu plus
l'histoire seuls huit poèmes et 9 en
choeur d'accord donc la diviser et la
plupart des textes nantes dans ces des
textes la fac bonnement massa couapel
l'entourage mais comment la vidéo pour
coup et pourquoi pas comme la vôtre et
vous demande alors si nous remontons ip
dans le temps mais là commence par créer
l'association
dans le sud on a cherché neutre asin et
comment elle a créé cette association là
et ne recommence participer au concours
organisé par le crij et c'est en fin de
compte comptait notamment l'alcool zamal
donc nous la participer ne l'a pas gagné
nous l'a pas gagné ce concours là
puisqu'une l'association l'objectif
c'était la prévention de la délinquance
donc nous voulons participer il n'a pas
gagné ce même titre la leaf est agité
les faîtages et à l'époque ce même titre
mal à soumettre mon camarade mon ami
daniel waro qui sera là pour le cabba à
lire d'ailleurs cilic l'a pris à moi
aussi moi écrire le créole quand la
graphie kwz c'est une piscine gratuit
non comment simone et rapide donc j'ai
passé une question me pose en six mois
et rapide peut-être pas prendre la la la
la langue et les suffisants six mois
pour apprendre à écrire même trois mois
encore oui donc passé à l'écrit et
appliquer ces règles de l'écrit il
devrait être pas si long que ça amène à
bombay le pas dans sa zone parce que je
tenais déjà bloqué d'accord ok au moins
les chaussons de la fait parce que des
tons plus légion les gens la procureure
céline dans des maisons de disques à
sous ou autre et maladie aux autres n'a
rien n'est facile dans la vie il faut
hisser devant la difficulté qu'on
apprend où mettre la tête et après on
prend plaisir pour revenir
comment la ville y décrit al gore mallet
c'est donc comme l écrit ce texte là
avec mon band jeunes de l'association de
tracy et ensuite ne pas dénier au
concours mal à rodin à danyel waro et à
transformer en babylone que l'été sur
notre premier cd que les sorties en 2001
et donc le titre fera grâce pour daniel
rossellat après que ma senti comme qu'
il n'y ait rambarde en mai l'école chez
tout bonnement malikov pourquoi me dis
ça parce que et moi même comme était
adolescent b comics aux comptes et qu'un
pack aux français mais ou sinon bon
marmaille et surtout à cet âge
cette génération que et demain comme
adrian donc mais monsieur le professeur
dora il y avait la question est où
l'avait la réponse où il avait une
certaine timidité frustration intervient
pas répond parce qu'une bonne camarade
rire de montreux
ben non justement
justement c'est là mon combat c'est que
mais tandis que le créole il y vient en
complément du français n'est pas pour
remplacer francis parce que quand nous
sautent la mer et piscine ou gay pas
mettre en mots français ndlr tu ne
gagnes pas défendre notre dame elle
mangeait d'après l'été après tu l'as été
pré sera pas comme nous narrera parce
que nous poserait alors ou écrit alors
midi en france est l'objectif de ce
livre valoriser notre langue maternelle
notre langue créole et assurer sa survie
par l'utilisation d'un des quatre
courants de graphie existants le nemo
qu'il est moins fort à assurer sa survie
on est d'accord de ligne survie oui il
me cale d'abord voir explique pourquoi
météo ça parce que nous nous causeront
peux que me revient un petit peu sur
l'historique mon premier livre c'était
bon enfant
si en 2007 et est préfacé par daniel
waro gilbert pounia puisque travail nous
parler de bana et pourquoi disant prêt
et mais revient avec un deuxième livre
2010 7 septembre 2010 est le trio
résister une fana parce que notre langue
créole en train de mourir donc nous
cause une cause ne l'écrit pas et rogue
même un grand militant d identité
culturelle réunionnaise
il y en a car les biens de lyme est un
problème pour lire folie après que mais
tout à fait ou pas fait d'effort avant
arriver dans la vie mais c'est aussi
parce qu'après kong écrite du languedoc
langue maternelle chez toi bo prend
plaisir à écrire écrire tout un club et
un expéditeur assuré d'accord avec karl
n'a pas consulté un minimum d'accord
parce que me direz pas par contre que la
langue elle est en train de mourir
mais me dit que la langue est en danger
il faut bien être conscient de ça que si
nous nous fait pas d effort chacun de
son côté pour que la langue continue à
vivre et à se développer à terme ni va
disparaître l'an pour l'instant lié pas
y'a pas encore disparu mais il faut il
faut que nous est conscient que l'élan
il peut mourir
on dit ça les gens croient pas ou l'élan
des bateaux battent sa main alors qu'en
haut commandement mais comme le propose
à sa de dexia est difficile plusieurs
contrées pas aigri par alors avant tout
mais les intervenants en langues et
cultures régionales rue du vau
directoire alors oui mais c'était quand
même un petit peu la démarche parce que
il prend vraiment un plaisir gourmand
mais là quelle que soit la toile elle
c'est le contexte environnemental parce
que ma femme tu peu partout dans toutes
les écoles
le contexte environnemental et changer
parce que le contexte qu'on a fait ce
histoire me l'a fait avec une grande
section l'école la saline comme migros
fait la même histoire avec un cm2
l'école le primat le contexte
environnemental les différents est
différent en fin de compte à ses bonnes
mains en mains ils ravagent bon peu mais
messi sous compan ds de travail que
sanaa
ces bons mâles les gentils en fin de
compte ceux qui recherchent une
affection parce que je réussisse bien
souvent des familles monoparentales et
la moment les livres et du tout seul
point et aux années n'a tout autour
d'eux dans un environnement nénin enap
tout ce qu'il faut pour que ça ne
réussit pas le contexte est
malheureusement malheureusement
millièmes
mais le contexte est pas là alors que
les histoires comme en mal à fait pour
répondre question jean paul c'est que
déjà combien arrive dans l'école mais
familiarise autres milliers des trois
fonds de cairns
il commence déjà familiarisé e avec mon
créole pour que ceux d'hier après ma
philosophie est mon idée c'est que il
faut le marmaille à des impôts qu'ils y
adhèrent
nous nous fait un vote ne choisit un
titre ne choisit un titre après chaque
normal
les missions sont même le bras mais les
timides vais pas participer il y donne
des idées même n'a rien à voir avec le
titre après la maison ça sous forme de
puzzle
parce que pourquoi pour que la finalité
et le maillot du bo pourra même pas pas
mon histoire
alors quand